hello everyone welcome to another
wonderful episode of ask IJ that's for
you guys ask me questions on the
internet and then I answer them here
in the form of a video I even have a
question
Twitter question if I saw a 30-foot tall
orange fluffy penguin what I keep it as
a pet what kind of question is that
where do you honestly think I'm going to
keep a 30-foot penguin obviously it's
not gonna fit in my apartment it's not
gonna fit in a cage I can keep it
outside but it's not gonna happen sorry
no penguin Leah wants to know if I'm
ever gonna do a video with nigahiga
I don't know do you want me to do a
video with him what kind of video would
you like to see if you wanted to do a
video with me maybe you guys should go
tell him to do a video with me
my feeling is about the iJustine game uh
yeah I don't really think it's ever
gonna go away Thank You Shane to act HR
wants to know what episode I'll be on of
Criminal Minds for those of you that
don't know I'm pretty excited could be
playing another dead body and that
episode airs on November 3rd here in the
United States I don't know when it airs
everywhere else baby birth question was
my first dailybooth picture I'm not sure
let me look wow that's a pretty great
picture my favorite pop chart flavor
brown sugar and cinnamon if I could
create any iPhone app what would I
create oh by far it would be be cooked
breakfast app because I don't like to
cook actually let me cook breakfast
lunch and dinner that would be more than
excellent hmm which hat should you wear
tomorrow I would say that one did I get
the PlayStation Move oh you better
believe it thank you for question in the
bat attack video - my sister actually
get attacked by a bat now if I told you
the truth I don't want you actually mad
she actually didn't get attacked by a
bat off the vlog was kind of boring
Sonia to spice it up a little bit so
yeah I lied okay Cece wants to know if I
actually will read that comment and
guess Casey I read it I read it play me
relax those of you that have not seen
Lion King and my fan of Lion King and
did I cry when Mufasa died I did in fact
cry and yes I am a fan YouTube question
video games do I play I played all the
mario games for Wii and I just recently
got a PlayStation 3 start of playing
modern warfare 2 and the new PlayStation
Move is so much fun it is a lot like Wii
but you know what whatever have I ever
been to the moon no no I haven't have
you
somebody thinks I'm Carrie Underwood but
I know yes as a matter of fact I was
that girl dancing in Fred's music video
if you haven't seen it check it out here
those dance skills are so-so God thank
you guys so much for watching this
episode of ask I J don't forget to click
subscribe that way you'll know when I
launch new videos such as wonderful last
guy J's I also check out my vlog channel
I post videos almost daily there so
check it out if you're wondering why I'm
not posting videos here all the time
because I got another channel so I post
stuff over there ah until then I will
see you guys later